-My first guest
is a very talented actor
that you know
from his work
in "Game of Thrones"
and "Aquaman."
Now he stars in "Dune,"
which hits theaters
and will be streaming
on HBO Max
starting October 22nd.
Here is the one and only
Jason Momoa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, come on now!
Come on now!
That's what I'm talking about.
Yeah!
I'm virtually hugging you,
buddy.
Look, Jason, we were talking
about you early.
You're one
of our favorite guests,
because you're just pure fun.
-I hope you mean that, bro.
I love your show.
-I do. I do. I mean it.
-I'll do it
whenever you want me to.
I love you.
-I know. I love you, buddy.
I know you're in London.
Thank you for doing this.
I appreciate this.
You're working on "Aquaman 2."
How is it going so far?
-Yep.
It's -- It's amazing,
but also...
-A lot of work.
-...very, very, very --
lots of -- lots of good --
lots of good injuries going on.
-[ Laughs ]
Yeah, yeah, awesome, bud.
I'm excited for that.
Please come back
when you have that come out.
Well, look, obviously, you know
I love you,
you're a great actor,
but you're also a very popular
Halloween costume.
Do you know this?
People can be Khal Drogo.
-I feel like I would be.
-There's a lot of good
characters.
-Yeah.
-There -- I have one here.
This is the perfect time of year
to go get your...
Everyone -- you too,
can look like Aquaman.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oh, man!
-Pretty realistic.
It looks like --
Now, did you -- When did you
model for this?
-Looks like a homeless man.
Looks like a homeless man.
-I don't know what this guy
looks like,
but it's --
-I don't know.
-It's almost like the GEICO
caveman or something.
I don't know what it is.
It's not --
-GEICO caveman feels right,
yeah.
-You actually have to have
Jason Momoa's face
to look like Jason Momoa.
But I wanted to prove it to you,
because I actually have --
I have one open right here,
if you want to --
-You should throw it on, buddy.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh [bleep]
[ Laughter ]
-[ Clears throat ]
-Get in here.
Do this.
[ Laughs ]
♪♪
Oh, man.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Laughs ]
Is that shaved out?
-Dude, oh, my God!
-Did you shave the --
-[ Laughs ]
Dude, the scar --
Yeah, the trademark scar
is on there.
[ Laughter ]
The trademark scar is in that.
-Wow.
-Dude, we look
like twin brothers.
Are you kidding?
[ Laughter ]
-[ Laughs ] Oh, my God.
This is like there's two --
It's like you're talking
to yourself!
[ Laughter ]
-Why am I doing an interview
with myself?
-I know, this is the weirdest
night ever!
But, hey, welcome back to
"The Tonight Show."
I'm Jason Momoa.
I'm hosting --
Special guest
hosting the show...tonight.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-No hands, no hands, though.
No hands.
Got to be like, "Yo."
Blow it, bro.
-[ Sputters ]
[ Laughter ]
-It's not so easy, is it?
-No, it's actually --
it's hard to pull off.
It's hard to be
Jason Momoa, yeah.
I don't know, you guys,
is this sexy or what?
[ Cheers and applause ]
They're feeling it.
I wanted to talk to you about --
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughing ] Oh, my God.
Hey, buddy, I want to do --
-You look like "Super Mario
Bros.," like in a movie.
-I have no idea who I look like.
This is the most ridiculous
thing I've ever seen.
But let's get serious.
Let's get ser--
[ Chuckles ]
Let's get serious for a second.
-Let's get serious.
-Okay.
-All right.
-Seriously.
All right, what are we doing?
-I'm sorry.
All right, here we go.
-Sorry.
-No problem.
Hey, I do want to talk about
"Dune."
[ Laughter ]
-This little
independent movie --
little independent movie
I've been doing lately?
That's pretty cool.
-By the way, it's unbelievable.
It is -- It's fantastic.
For real, I have to say it
wearing this,
but you -- it's crusher,
it's gorgeous.
It's a beautiful movie.
-Well, he's the best.
Denis is -- it's amazing,
and I'm with
the most all-star cast
I've ever worked with
in my life.
-You got a little
Timothee Chalamet.
You got some Chalamet love
in there.
-Yeah, I got Timmy boy --
Timmy boy is in there.
-We like that guy.
How is working with Timothee?
-He's amazing.
-Yeah.
-I mean, like, he's such a --
he's the next generation of,
just stud.
He's so intelligent.
He's a New Yorker.
-Yep.
-He's beautiful. I love him.
-And everyone should love him,
'cause he's amazing.
-How did you -- How did you get
to be in "Dune?"
Were you a fan of the original
book or the movie?
Or were -- Did you like
the director, or both?
-No, man, I have no idea.
'Cause I was -- I was at --
I was at Sundance,
and I got a call.
And it was Denis who wanted to
meet with me.
And then I came
off the mountain.
I was kind of in shock because
he's my favorite director.
-He's brilliant.
-And then he basically
pitched me the movie.
He showed me, like, everything,
and said "I want you."
And no one's ever wanted me.
No one's ever hired me
off the thing.
And, like, my favorite director
is asking me
to play, to me,
one of the most --
the greatest characters
in the series.
-It's a work of art, dude.
You've got to be proud.
-Yeah, man.
Thank you.
-Like, I'm pretty proud.
Look at me.
-I'm excited for America --
I'm excited
for the world to see it.
It's -- I'm super proud.
Yeah.
The cast is insane.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Jason Momoa in "Dune."
Take a look at this.
♪♪
-Duncan!
-No! Duncan!
-Paul, no!
-Duncan, no!
-No!
-He's locked the door.
♪♪
-Yeah, that's my man!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Jason Momoa, everybody!
"Dune" is in theaters
and streaming on HBO Max
starting October 22nd.